it's great life
i won't change it for anything
i was a model
i was always in heels and pumps and
platform shoes and i worried about my
weight
there just came a time i just said
enough you know i'm not happy anymore
i came to alaska with one dog and about
500 in my pocket because i wanted to be
a sled dog musher
i knew that life in alaska was for me
basically the moment i stepped off the
airplane
i got here and the mountains just blew
me away
it's like how some people feel when they
see the ocean
i personally don't feel isolated at all
in alaska because i'm surrounded by a
lot of dogs and a lot of family
racing is fun and i enjoy that but
there's a great need for rescue in
alaska
we take dogs that are rejected from
other teams and other kennels
they all have their own unique stories
and this is to me the most rewarding
work we can do
i'm training for the iditarod 2016.
the iditarod is the world's longest and
probably most well-known sled dog race
it's a thousand miles
starts in the anchorage and goes to
gnome and it covers some amazing country
and it goes up on the coast up on the
bering sea
to be on the sled with the dogs feels
amazing
you're part of this wild world where
there's caribou and there's moose and
you got the sunrise you got the sunset
you get the stars over you get the moon
over you
and it's a great feeling to be a part of
that
you